الأشخاص الذين لا يقومون بعملك
يقولون جيدًا إن الأمر ليس بهذا السوء ومع ذلك فهو ليس
بهذا السوء ، ولكن كيف يبدو الأمر الآن
سيئًا كما لو رأيت
أي شيء من قبل قبل أن أفعل هذا لمدة
20 عامًا وأنا  لم أرها بهذا السوء من قبل ،
فأنا أقوم بالرعاية الحرجة لفترة طويلة
وهؤلاء هم المرضى الأكثر مرضًا
الذي رأيته على الإطلاق ، لقد اعتدنا على
رعاية المرضى المرضى في وحدة العناية المركزة
الأولى والثانية ومن ثم لدينا بعض المرضى السهل
هذا  واحدًا تلو الآخر ، لدينا ست
وحدات العناية المركزة مفتوحة بالفعل ، وهي مخصصة
لمرضى كوفاك ، وجميعهم
يخضعون للتهوية الميكانيكية ، وجميعهم
يخضعون للتخدير ، وقد أصيبوا بالشلل
بقدر ما يمكن أن يكون لدينا
مرضى أكثر مرضًا في الطوابق العادية التي
عادة ما نفعلها  لدينا في الجليد ولكن
ليس لدينا مساحة لهم ، لذا فإن الحقيقة
هي أن كل وحدة العناية المركزة التي نفتحها لدينا وحدة العناية
المركزة الأخرى جاهزة للذهاب اليوم ، لقد
افتتحنا وحدة العناية المركزة الخامسة أو السادسة ، لكن الوحدة التي
كنت أعمل فيها اليوم كانت تحتوي فقط على ثمانية أو
تسعة مرضى في البداية ملأنا ما
يصل إلى 21 وكيل  s ثم افتح الصندوق الذي
أراكم جميعًا على جهاز التنفس الصناعي جميعًا
مريض قدر الإمكان وهو
يزداد سوءًا ويزداد الأمر سوءًا كل يوم
كل يوم نسمع المزيد والمزيد من
المرضى كل يوم نسمع
صوتًا فوق الأنبوب للتنبيب  التخدير
ليأتي وينبثق الناس ونحن نتأرجح في
كل مرة نسمع ذلك فوق
لأننا نعرف وما الذي يذهب إليه المريض على
جهاز التنفس الصناعي ويأتي إلى وحدة العناية المركزة ،
قمنا بالتعدين عن واحد من
خلال محاولة التنبيب في أي مكان
ممكن نعتني به للإشراف على بعض الأطباء
وتقول الممرضات والممرضات على الخطوط الأمامية إن
مستشفياتهم تواجه
طوفانًا هائلاً من المرضى ، وهناك مرضى
يتراكمون وجميع الممرات التي تحتوي
على الأكسجين تعمل بها خزانات الأكسجين
أحب الغرف قصيرة ، طاقم التمريض
قصير ، يتصل الأطباء
بغرفة الطوارئ هذه  يقول الأطباء إن النقص
في مستويات خطيرة
ونفاد الأدوية ونفد من
المعدات ونفد حتى من
الأكسجين وهو أمر يحدث
التي أغلقت في تسعة عشر تعني أن
أحد أهم أوجه النقص في أجهزة التهوية
هو أن حبك مليء
بالسوائل كما لو كنت تغرق ، وبمجرد
أن تصل إلى النقطة التي تغرق فيها ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى جهاز التنفس الصناعي للبقاء على قيد الحياة
وهم "  إعادة نفاد تلك المعدات
للأشخاص الذين يتسابقون لملء المؤخرة ، تقوم
نيويورك الآن على وجه السرعة ببناء
مستشفيات ميدانية للطوارئ في مركز جافيتس في
سنترال بارك وفي أماكن أخرى وحول
المدن الريفية التي تستعد
للتأثير تسارع لبناء قدراتها
في حالة  تعرضت للتسونامي نفسه الذي تعرضت له
مدينة نيويورك في فريدريكسبيرغ ، فرجينيا ، على بعد
حوالي ساعة جنوب
مستشفى واشنطن ، أقامت مستشفى ماري واشنطن مستشفى ميدانيًا
في مرآب السيارات على
بعد أقدام قليلة خارج غرفة الطوارئ الخاصة
بها ، وسنبدأ في
محطات الفرز  لكننا سنكون قادرين على توسيع نطاق
ذلك لأننا نحتاج إلى طبيب الطوارئ ، يأخذنا إريك توش من
خلال ما يشبه وحدة MASH
مع أجهزة الأشعة السينية المحمولة
ووحدات الأكسجين التي يتم حقنها في الوريد  رأى
توش ما كان يحدث في أكثر المدن تضررًا ، كما قال توش ، وتم تشغيل هذا المرفق
في غضون أيام قليلة ، لا يوجد الآن
سوى عدد قليل من مرضى الفيروس التاجي داخل
المستشفى الرئيسي ، ولا يوجد أي منهم في المستشفى الميداني ،
لكن توش واثق من أنه
سيتغير كما نسمع من زملائه في نيو.
يورك في نيو أورلينز أنهم يرون
ما يصل إلى مائتين إلى أربعمائة
من حجمهم اليومي العادي ، لذا فقد تم
تصميم هذا النوع من التدفق ،
حيث تطلب بعض البراعة الإبداعية ، حيث
أخذ المستشفى كراسي منطقة الانتظار
القديمة وحولها إلى كراسي علاج
ومدخلات
شعيرات نباتية قديمة سنقوم بإعادة توظيفها
كحاملات أكياس وريدية وقد قاموا بتثبيت
ميزة واقعية إلى حد ما يأمل توش
ألا يضطر فريقه إلى استخدامها أبدًا
في حالة تعرض المرضى للعنف حيث سيتمكن الأشخاص الذين
يحتاجون إلى الخروج من الخروج
عبر الجزء الخلفي من الخيمة هنا
وفي منطقة العلاج الرئيسية ، كيس كاي الآنسة كاي ،
نعم
تقول إدارة السلامة والصحة المهنية إنه يوازن الآن بين
الاستعداد لإدارة مخاوف
ومخاوف مرحبًا  فريق العمل حول ما قد
يأتي ، لا أعلم أن أي شخص على قيد الحياة
قد رأى شيئًا كهذا ،
لكننا تلقينا الكثير من التدريب على
المرونة والإبداع والقيام بالأشياء
بالطريقة التي ربما لم يكن من المفترض
أن يتم تصميمها أو تصميمها  القيام بشيء واحد د.
يشعر توش بالقلق الآن بشأن
انخفاض عدد المرضى الذين يبحثون عن
علاج طارئ خارج فيروس كورونا ، وقد
رأى عددًا أقل بكثير من المرضى يأتون إلى هنا
بحثًا عن العلاج من النوبات القلبية
والسكتات الدماغية على مدار الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ، ويقول
إنهم جميعًا يخشون من ذهابهم
للحصول على فيروس كورونا بريان تود سي إن إن
فريدريكسبيرج فيرجينيا
، لقد تغيرت الطريقة التي يدير بها الانسجام الممرضات
والأطباء في مركز هاربورفيو الطبي في سياتل ،
suda2 لمعركة
فيروس كورونا ، عليهم أن يخضعوا
لنظام ارتداء ملابس شامل أغطية
وأنابيب وأقنعة وأردية فقط للدخول
إلى غرفة المريض.  أعتقد أن الخطر الأكبر في
الواقع على العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية هو
عندما يزيلون الأشياء التي
يلوثونها بأنفسهم ، يكون لديهم
قائمة مرجعية ومراقب يساعد في
كل خطوة عليهم أيضًا التكيف مع
الحقائق الجديدة ونقص هذه
الآلات وترشيح الهواء بالداخل
لأنهم كانوا كذلك.  تم بناؤه
للاستخدام لمرة واحدة ، لكن هذا ليس هو الحال إذا
فعلنا ذلك ، فسنكون سيد الشباب واو
لديهم  تم تجديده بالكامل ليشمل
وحدات العناية المركزة ، لذا
كان من المفترض أن تكون هذه الوحدة بأكملها مخصصة للأشخاص الذين يعانون من
إصابات وسكتات دماغية وما إلى ذلك ، ولذا
يتعين علينا الآن المضي قدمًا معهم جميعًا في
مكان آخر لأنه يتعين علينا
مواصلة هذه الرعاية حتى يتمكن جميع الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من دماغ  تم نقل الإصابات
وتم تحويل هذا إلى وحدة Koba 19 ICU
لتصحيح كل شيء لمحاولة مساعدة مرضى الفيروس التاجي على
العيش في عزلهم عن الآخرين
والحفاظ على سلامة الموظفين أيضًا
حتى لا أرتدي
معدات الحماية الشخصية الكاملة لأنه في هذه
الغرف حيث يوجد الرمز الفعلي  19 مريضًا
يعتبرون
غرف ضغط سلبي ، مما يعني أننا
نعتبر في مكان آمن لا نرتدي
حماية شخصية كاملة.
تتم رعاية صفحتين ولكننا
لا نحتاج إلى ارتداء الجهاز بالكامل
إلا إذا كنت طبيبًا أو ممرضة لديها
للدخول إلى الغرفة للعناية
بالمريض داخل الغرف ، يتم
توصيل المرضى بعدد صادم من الأنابيب
باستخدام تلك المراوح الثمينة ،
الشيء الوحيد الذي يحفظهم  يتنفسون لذلك بالنسبة
لمرضى وحدة العناية المركزة الذين يميلون إلى
البقاء ، فإنهم يمرضون بشدة ويظلون مرضى
لفترة طويلة جدًا ، لذا فإن تناول الطعام يتطلب جهاز
التنفس الصناعي لأسابيع في كل مرة
وهذه هي المشكلة الكبيرة الموجودة
هناك فقط للمستشفيات تم إدخال ستين مريضًا بفيروس كورونا
إلى المستشفى الأسبوع الماضي
بالفعل  هذا الأسبوع ، كانت 100
رقصة لكل واحدة على الأقل لإبقاء الموظفين
بصحة جيدة والمرضى على قيد الحياة ، لقد
أتت للتو إلى هنا ورؤية العمل
الذي يتم إنجازه ورؤية
المرضى الذين يتلقون الرعاية ، إنه أمر
مرهق ، أشعر بالخوف على أسرهم لأنهم
حسنًا ، يفعلون كل ما يحتاجون إليه
لرعاية المرضى ، إنه يفكر في
حقيقة أنهم أيضًا قد يعرضون
أنفسهم للخطر خارج
المستشفى ، وقد تم نصب خيمة
كبيرة لتقييم واختبار مرضى فيروس كورونا
المحتملين وهذا يحدث قبل
الزيادة المتوقعة هنا.
أشعر بالرهبة وأشعر بالخوف وأنا لا
أعمل في الخطوط الأمامية ، ما الذي
تشعر به وأنت تتعامل مع كل هذه الأمور ،
إنه حقًا حد ذاته  nse من القلق
لأننا نعلم الآن
أننا نتساءل نوعًا ما عما
سيكون عليه الحال لن يتدفق مرة أخرى بينما يبدو
أن عدد الإصابات الجديدة في
واشنطن يتباطأ
وهناك شعور متزايد بأنهم لم
يروا أسوأ ما في  ومع ذلك ، فإن ما يفعلونه
كل يوم هو ذهاب بطولي
والعناية بالمرضى دون حماية
ليست كذلك